I hate snake shot I hate him I have
actually
no fear of snakes
that's acting
hey I hey I'm Harrison Ford these are
some of the biggest moments from Indiana
Jones let's start with dialer destiny
[Music]
get back
I really don't think there's something
that distinguishes dial of Destiny from
all the other films I think that's a
there's a Continuum the whole film is
about time and about wrinkles in time
and these are the wrinkles and
the time I think is apparent we wanted
to make I wanted to make a film about
about the end
of his life I wanted to see all of the
development of his personality that
we've seen and then I wanted to see him
after the passage of the 15 years that
actually exists between the last film
that we did and and this one I've
changed I'm not the Young Buck I once
was I'm an older man I would like the
audience to appreciate that in the
context of his life and to see what
effect time has on the character the cut
from from the first previous 25 minutes
to arriving in
1969 on moon day is one of the favorite
things I've ever done in movies I think
it's just a great visual construction
and a great character moment
[Music]
he did that scene where guys got him
around the neck and indy like flips his
body back to knock the guy off and
that's where Harrison's back went he let
out a a call for help at that point well
it's a dangerous work environment
the good news is Harrison Ford is fine
he feels great his enzyme papaya
treatment worked fantastically well I'm
especially interested in this papaya
treatment well they stopped doing them
about 30 years ago because they were
dissolving people's spinal columns
mine's intact that was Temple of a doom
yeah Raiders was the ACL Run Over By The
Flying Wing in Tunisia collection was
done in the stunt Department to figure
out how I might be able to work the next
day yeah
[Music]
I think that locations are essential to
the Indiana Jones films and I'm so glad
that we are committed to working in real
physical environments it's occasionally
very useful to stand in front of a blue
screen and imagine that you're gazing
out from the top of the Eiffel Tower or
the City of Paris and you're not if you
don't have to do that you can smell
Morocco you can feel Morocco your extras
are actually Moroccan it's just nothing
like being in the real place and seeing
a real place how many of our audience
will get a chance to visit those
environments Sicily where we had actual
ruins from Greek and Roman history that
was a wonderful
environment places like the caves part
of the caves are done in actual physical
caves and the others are sets because of
the complicated scenes that we had to do
in them
Christmas
there's no cookies
ironically when I was a assistant
counselor in the in the nature
Department of Boy Scout camp in
Wisconsin I made it my mission to dig a
reptile
pit which I then peopled with
reptiles that I collected
and I got to know snakes uh firsthand
basis I have actually no fear of snakes
that's acting my parents were
inefficient in curtailing my impulses I
raised a black and white hooded rats
great numbers of black and white rats
running around my room
and eventually my house and my
neighborhood that was a very successful
rat razor no wheels were harmed in the
making of This production because there
were no eels that's
just what you do
I gotta tell you something don't get
sentimental not dead save it till we get
out of here the floor's on fire Sean is
an amazing performer pure fun working
with him we enjoyed a great relationship
well made it
when we're Airborne with Germany behind
us then I'll share that sentiment well I
played it without my trousers and
Harrison's I said you're not gonna
played to see me without your trousers I
said well if I don't I'll be stopping
all the time because I sweat enormously
I sweat very easily
well he did the same he was a heavy
sweater yes and he wore a heavy uh wool
pants and he did appear without his
pants because of the Heat and I felt it
both necessary and appropriate to remove
my pants so we had two pantsless men
photographed from the waist of film
history
Shia's character Mutt our our son we
have this confined story about him it
was the screenwriter's invention to have
lost a child to complicate the
relationship between myself and Marion
in order to retrieve that relationship
his name is Henry Henry good name it's
your son
my son I mean it's all part of the
fabric of telling a film story
[Music]
that should do it incredible clip of you
stapling your hat to your head I still
have the
see it if you do what you need to do
[Music]
it was presented to me as a aspect of
character uh in the first film my
questions about it were many why am I
wearing a leather jacket in the jungle
isn't it hot here
why am I carrying a whip what am I going
to do with it
whip you're gonna whip people
oh okay
and the hat was an evocation of a time a
period you know a reflection
of uh movies past oh oh okay I said okay
and that makes it my own
[Music]
foreign